the people that run corporations are
[ __ ] lunatics these people just even
people who are involved and with this
the designed obsolescence where
everything you just have to [ __ ]
throw out I was talking the other day
how like you'd buy a [ __ ] TV when I
was a kid you had it for like 25 years
we could all at some point just say hey
you know what I think the picture's
clear enough it's like a new phone every
year new phone charger every year isn't
the new charger doesn't work that the
old charger you just gotta throw it all
out and places like that from what I
heard don't want to get sued they they
would rather pay the fine the fine is so
much less than the money that they make
and you go goddamn well those
corporations they give money they give
money and they give money to these
politicians yeah it's all just shut them
the [ __ ] up so they can keep the fact
that you can't drink water out of a
river anywhere
yeah in my lifetime that that happened
you gotta drink bottled water and all
that these corporations poisoned
the water supply dude if I do that you
do that that's a terrorist act you're
you're in jail for the rest of your life
these [ __ ] guys ding ding ding ding
ding ding [ __ ]